Ich bin bereit. Okay, darf ich die Uhr sehen?
Könnte ich?
Leider. Ich kann einfach getrennt eingestellt und am Ende kann ich Ihnen sagen.
Okay, dann mache ich meine... Okay. Guten Tag, mein Name ist Ipek.
Ich bin hier als Arztin-Arzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmegespräch führen. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Morgen, Frau Doktor. Ich heiße Martina Stema.
Martina?
Stema.
Martina buchstabiert sich M, A, R, T, I wie Ida, N und am Ende A wie Anton.
Stema buchstabiert sich S, T, E wie Emil, Doppel M wie Martha, E wie Emil und am Ende R wie Richard.
Vielen Dank für die Buchstabierungen. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Stema?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23.02.1965.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,65 Meter groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 65,7 Kilo.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen. Frau Stema, was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Frau Doktor, ich habe seit heute Morgen so komische Schmerzen in der Brust.
Vor einer Stunde bin ich nach dem Feierabend hier gekommen.
Okay, ich verstehe. Was bedeutet Sie mit komischen Schmerzen?
Wie Gefühl oder haben Sie gleichzeitig Herzrasen, Brustschmerzen?
Wie gesagt, das ist Brustschmerzen und es ist ein Druck, Frau Doktor, ein Druck hinter dem Brustbein.
Vor einer Stunde haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Nein.
Verstehe ich richtig?
Eine Stunde vor Feierabend.
Okay.
Ungefähr seit 3 Stunden.
Diese Schmerzen verstehe ich ganz plötzlich aufgetreten.
Plötzlich während der Arbeit aufgetreten.
Okay. Kennen Sie diese Schmerzen? Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Schmerzen?
Ja, in der Vergangenheit hatte ich aber leichter. Vielleicht vor 4 Wochen hatte ich solche Schmerzen.
Vor 4 Wochen.
Ja, das war aber leichter.
Was bedeutet leichter? Zum Beispiel denken wir diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10.
Ganz leichte Schmerzen sind 10 am stärksten Schmerzen. Wie schätzen Sie diese Schmerzen ein?
Jetzt ist es ein bisschen besser. Aber am Anfang, während der Arbeit, konnte ich sagen 5 und 10.
Aber jetzt ist es ein bisschen leichter als vorherige Schmerzen. Ich würde jetztige Schmerzen 3 sagen.
Okay, 3. Vor 4 Wochen, wie können Sie?
Vor 4 Wochen, leichter. Wenn ich schnell bewege oder wenn ich mich schnell bewege oder bei Belastung hatte ich vorherige leichte Schmerzen.
Aber heute gab es keine Belastung oder Stress. Es gab kein Ungewöhnliches.
Sind diese Schmerzen immer dauerhaft oder gehen sie manchmal wieder weg?
Dauerhaft, Herr Doktor.
Aber früher, meine ich vor 4 Wochen, wenn es ruhig war, sind die Schmerzen selbst verschwunden.
Ja, selbst gegangen. Aber heute nicht.
Heute dauerhaft da. Okay. Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzkarakter beschreiben?
Sie haben gesagt, drückend und anders brennende Gefühle oder dumpfe Schmerzen.
Ich kann auch dumpf hinzufügen. Drückend und dumpf.
Okay. Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, Frau Doktor. Zum Beispiel in die Schulter, ins Heiß oder?
Ja, in der, ich spüre Rücken vielleicht zwischen meinen Schultern.
Ah, zwischen. Okay. Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für diese Schmerzen? Zum Beispiel bei Belastung etwas schwer aufhoben, tragen?
Nein, Frau Doktor. In der Regel habe ich viel Stress bei der Arbeit. Ich bin Taxifahrerin.
Aber während des Anfangs dieser Schmerzen hatte ich Stress.
Ich sitze in meinem Auto. Aber ich habe in meinem Auto einfach gesetzt und ich habe auf die Kunden, auf die Vergesst. gewartet.
Währenddessen hatte ich diese Schmerzen. Es gab keine Besonderes.
Okay. Haben Sie Übelkeit gleichzeitig diese Schmerzen oder Erbrüchen?
Ja, Frau Doktor. Mir war übel. Und ich habe einmal erbrochen.
Okay. Einmal erbrochen. Frau Stema, ich möchte Ihnen nicht unberuhigen, aber ich würde gerne diese Aufnahmegespräche unterbrechen,
einen EKG durchführen, einen Blut abnehmen, um die Herzkrankheit auszuschließen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente Allergien?
Nein, ich bin allergisch nur gegen Nickel.
Okay. Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank.
Frau Doktor, danke. Ich habe Angst davor, weil mein Bruder vor einem Jahr einen Herzinfarkt erlitten hat.
Deswegen wurde bei ihm ein Bypass durchgeführt.
Wie alt war er während der Krankheit?
Er war 55.
Okay. Das ist gut.
Er war jahrelang alt.
Der Bypass lief gut?
Ja, Gott sei Dank. Alles war in Ordnung.
Okay. Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Mit diesen Untersuchungen können wir beurteilen.
Und jetzt sind Sie im Krankenhaus. Wir sind da.
Können wir unsere Gespräche weitermachen.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Erbruch?
Morgen habe ich während der Arbeit als Frühstück ein Käsebrotchen gegessen.
Essenröste.
Fühlen Sie sich febrikt oder haben Sie Kaltschweiß?
Ja, genau. Ich hatte auch Kaltschweiß.
Während dieser Schmerzen?
Am Anfang der starksten Phase hatte ich auch Kaltschweiß.
Haben Sie auch Nachtschweiß oder anders bemerkt?
Ich fühle mich sehr müde, Frau Doktor.
Natürlich.
Ich bin ganz kalt.
Okay.
Ich bin für Sie da. Wir machen alle Schritt für Schritt.
Ihre Angst ist nachvollziehbar.
Haben Sie auch Wasserlassenprobleme? Stuhlgangprobleme?
Nein, Frau Doktor. Ich habe keine Probleme.
Ich vermute Sie nicht.
Weder mit dem Stuhlgang noch beim Wasserlassen.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Apathit?
Jetzt nicht, aber in der Regel habe ich keine Apathitprobleme.
Probleme mit Apathit.
Gut. Wie ist Ihr Gewichtveränderung?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gewicht ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt, Frau Doktor.
Ich vermute Sie schlafen nicht so gut.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen oder bei der Stress.
Sie haben ganz richtig vermutet.
Seit wann haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Mindestens seit Jahren. Vielleicht seit fünf Jahren leide ich darunter.
Okay. Dagegen nehmen Sie ein Medikament oder haben Sie irgendeinen Arzt besucht?
Nein, deswegen war ich niemals beim Arzt.
Dagegen nehme ich Baldrian.
Ist es schlafenreich?
Ja, teilweise.
Okay. Verstehe.
Okay. Und ich möchte wissen, ob Sie etwas über Ihre Erkrankungen brauchen.
Ich brauche ein paar Informationen.
Bevor das, möchten Sie mir etwas hinzufügen über Ihre jetzigen Beschwerden?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen soll.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe diese Probleme.
Und das jetzige größte Problem für mich ist vielleicht wichtiger als diese Schmerzen.
Angst. Ich habe Angst vor Tod.
Das macht mich sehr beunruhigt.
Ich verstehe. Und ich bin hier für Sie.
Ihre Angst ist ganz verständlich.
Das ist ganz normal mit Brustschmerzen.
Diese Angst kann man haben.
Aber wir werden unser Bestes für Sie tun.
Okay. Versuchen Sie bitte ruhig zu sein.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Vielen Dank. Das macht mir Spaß.
Ich habe Ihnen ein Ruhemittel verabschieden.
Es funktioniert ungefähr 5 Minuten oder so.
Okay.
Sie sind die Ersten.
Sie wissen besser.
Leiden Sie unter Krönchenerkrankungen?
Ich meine Bluthochdruck, Glutzucker.
Die erhöhten die Pithorte.
Solche Probleme habe ich nicht.
Aber ich habe Varizin.
Seit wann?
Deswegen wurde bei mir eine Operation durchgeführt.
Eine Entfernungoperation.
Ich habe seit 5 Jahren eine Erste.
Ich habe Rauchhusten.
Ich habe Probleme mit meinem Kniegelenk.
Ich denke, das ist eine Kniegelenkartrose.
Darüber habe ich im Internet gelesen.
Okay.
Wurde Ihr Arthrose schon operiert?
Nein.
Diese Diagnose habe ich festgestellt.
Haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Vorerkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Nein.
Oder nehmen Sie andere Medikamente,
außerdem bei Baldrian ein?
Ja, manchmal nehme ich Ibuprofen.
Wie viele Milligramm?
Für meinen Kniegelenkschmerzen.
Okay. Wie viele Milligramm?
400 Milligramm.
Okay. Danke schön.
Und noch nehmen Sie andere Medikamente?
Nein, nur diese beiden, Baldrian und Ibuprofen.
Okay. Ich würde wissen,
hatten Sie andere Vorerkrankungen,
außer der Barisenoperation?
Nein, nur diese Operation.
Die war jetzt in der Kranfadaentfernung.
Sie hatten gesagt, Sie haben Nikälerallergien.
Ja, richtig.
Wie reagiert es aus?
Mit Juckreis, Frau Doktor.
Starker Juckreis.
Und Rötungen, Hautrötungen.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein.
Glykos, Laktos?
Ich kann alle Lebensmittel vertragen
und alle Lebensstress erdulden.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie täglich?
Ja, du.
Sie haben Rauchherkosten?
Ja.
Trotzdem konnte ich nicht damit aufhören.
Haben Sie versucht, aufzuhören?
Ja, viermal.
Viermal? Das ist ganz gut.
Mehrmals.
Ganz gut versucht.
Mehr als viermal.
Seitdem ich 16 Jahre alt war, rauche ich.
Ungefähr täglich wie viel?
Eine Schachtel.
Okay, eine Schachtel.
Sprechen wir darüber nach dem Aufnahmegesprach.
Vielleicht ist das eine neue Chance für Sie,
um die Rauchen aufzuhören.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gelegentlich trinke ich Alkohol.
Ein Glas Altbeer vielleicht am Wochenende.
Oder Samstagabend.
Okay. Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein. Warum fragen Sie darüber?
Das ist ganz wichtig zu wissen.
Drogen hat Nebenwirkungen für die Gesundheit.
Nicht nur für die Gesundheit, auch für die ganze Gesellschaft.
Ich bin Taxifahrer und beobachte jeden Tag viele schlechte Zähne.
Drogen sind ein großes Problem.
Besonders für die Jungen.
Heutzutage haben Sie recht.
Sie sind Taxifahrerin.
Wohnen Sie alleine oder mit Ihrer Familie?
Ich wohne mit meiner Tochter und meinem Enkelkind.
Sie sind eine Familie.
Aber nicht eine richtige Familie.
Meine Tochter ist alleinerziehend.
Wir haben viel Stress bei der Familie.
Ich bin geschieden und alle Aufgaben...
Ich bin verantwortlich für alle.
Bei der Arbeit, zu Hause oder im ganzen Leben.
Das ist schwer.
Leiden Ihre Mutter oder Vater an einer chronischen Krankheit?
Leiden?
Ja, leider ist meine Mutter vor 30 Jahren an Schlaganfall verstorben.
Mein Vater leidet an Demenz, Frau Doktor.
Er sitzt im Rollstuhl und wohnt im Altenheim.
Ihre Mutter ist gestorben?
Meine Mutter ist gestorben vor 30 Jahren.
Aber ich kann mich nicht um meinen Vater kümmern.
Das ist auch Stress für mich.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Frau Stema, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld.
Es handelt sich um Ihre Beschwerden.
Sie sprechen über Durchblutung des Herzens.
Sie sollen ins Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ich werde mit meinem Obert Arz...
Wird das dort möglich sein?
Ich würde gerne Sie engmaschig beurteilen.
Sie müssen überwachen und eine bestimmte Behandlung planen.
Ich habe auch ein kardiologisches Konsul.
Sie kommt gleich und beurteilt ihr Herz.
Okay, natürlich.
Was ist das für eine Opere?
Das ist ganz früh zu sagen.
Zuerst muss ein kardiologisches Konsul überprüfen.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Behandlung.
Ich komme gleich. Danke sehr.
Bis dann. Tschüss.
Bis gleich.
Ich bin schon da.
Willst du einen Anruf machen?
Link, Link.
Guten Tag. Ich habe den Apparat.
Herr Müller vom Auslabor.
Es gibt einen Auslabor von Kalium.
Das ist 6,78 Millimitern pro Liter.
Der Patientname ist Frau Hagenbauch.
Frau Hagenbauch?
Okay.
Kaliumwerte könnten Sie bitte buchstabilen.
6,78.
7,8.
Vielen Dank. Frau Hagenbauch?
Bauch.
Okay. Vielen Dank.
H-A-G-E-N-B-A-U-S-H.
Vielen Dank, Herr Müller. Schönen Tag. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Okay.
Guten Tag, Frau.
Ipek, oder?
Ja, Ipek.
Dein Nachname ist Ipek?
Ja.
Richtig.
Ich nutze meinen Nachname.
Vorname ist anders.
Okay.
Vorname ist schwer ein bisschen.
Deswegen ist Ipek einfach.
Okay.
Können Sie sich kurz vorstellen?
Gerne.
Ich bin ...
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Und ... ja.
Nach fünf ... seit fünf Jahren bin ich in Deutschland.
Ich arbeite in der Türkei als Hausärztin.
Ich würde gerne in Deutschland auch in der Praxis als Hausarztin arbeiten.
Ich bin verheiratet und ich habe zwei Söhne.
In Deutschland habe ich einen Deutschkurs besucht.
Und letztes Mal einen Fachsprachkurs besucht.
Ich habe ungefähr sechs Monate Hospitalisierung gemacht.
Sechs Monate?
Ja.
Aber in der Woche ...
Welche Inwahl von Fachrichtungen haben Sie eine Hospitalisierung gemacht?
Ich habe bei einem Hausarzt eine Hospitalisierung gemacht.
Aber sechs Monate, nur zwei Tage, acht Stunden.
Insgesamt acht Stunden pro Woche.
Insgesamt acht Stunden.
Ich bin in die Hospitalisierung gegangen.
Ja.
Früher gab es zwei Hausärzte.
Leider ...
... der Boss ...
Er hat meine Bewerbung akzeptiert.
Leider ist er anderthalb Monate später verstorben.
Deswegen arbeite ich mit dem Kardiologen.
Natürlich war er immer beschäftigt.
Ich kann nur etwas beobachten.
Nichts ...
Ja.
Aber nur beobachtet?
Nur beobachtet, ja.
Nichts zu viel.
Wann haben Sie Ihr Medizinstudium abgeschlossen?
2004.
Sind Sie Fachärztin in der Türkei?
Ja.
Ich habe ...
... meinen ...
... Fachabschluss ...
... in 2015 gemacht.
Welche Fachrichtungen?
In der Türkei ein bisschen anders ...
... wie in Deutschland.
Ich habe ...
Nach dem Studium ...
... studieren ...
... sechs Monate, fünf Monate ...
... in der Medizin.
Ich habe Weiterbildung.
Ich hatte Weiterbildung.
Zum Beispiel sechs Monate in der Medizin.
Vier Monate Frauenärztin.
Fünf Monate Pädiatrie.
Und zwei Monate Kardiologen.
Dann bekomme ich ...
... Hausarztfachmedizin.
In der Türkei ist es ein bisschen anders.
Wie kann ich das erklären?
Du musst das nicht erklären.
Du solltest das nicht erklären.
Du kannst einfach sagen,
ich habe die Weiterbildung für Allgemeinmedizin gemacht.
Das ist recht.
Okay.
Dann ...
Vielleicht könnten Sie das nicht gut verstehen.
Sie könnten verstehen, dass du ...
... fünf Monate lang in der Medizin, sechs Monate lang ...
Frauenärztin ...
Sie können denken, jede Weiterbildung ist getrennt.
Ja.
Einfach?
In Allgemeinmedizin habe ich eine Weiterbildung gemacht.
Okay.
Und jetzt bin ich hier.
Ich möchte gerne ...
... in Deutschland arbeiten.
Zuerst weiß ich nicht, vielleicht in der Medizin oder so.
Aber ich möchte gerne direkt im Arbeitsumfeld ...
... anfangen.
Ja.
Anfangen.
Okay, was haben Sie heute für uns?
Heute habe ich eine Frau, Martina Stämme, aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich sie möchte, soll ich Ihnen eine Anmerkung geben.
Ich habe gerade einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Frau Hagenbauch hat ...
... von Kaliumwert ...
Frau Hagenbauch hat einen Kaliumwert von 7,6.
7,8.
Es ist ...
Was ist Einheit?
Millimiter pro Liter.
Es gibt einen Kaliumwert von Hyperkalemi.
Was ist der häufigste Ursache für Hyperkalemi?
Der häufigste Ursache für Hyperkalemi ...
Entschuldigung.
Hyperkalemi ...
Vielleicht auch die Urethika.
Und ...
Wie ...
Behandlung ...
Wo ist mein ...
Ja, ich bin ...
Ich möchte nur hören, was Sie wissen.
Was Sie wissen?
Hyperkalemi soll ich ein bisschen überlegen, aber diese Antwort geht nicht.
Muss ich auswendig sagen.
Hyperkalemi ...
Wegen der Ursache ...
Vielleicht ...
Die Urethika, ich habe gesagt.
Und vielleicht ...
Welche Urethika kann ich per Kalemi verwenden?
Per Kalemi ... Algenzidron ... Nein, nicht Alderzidron.
Vielleicht ...
Lupusdiurethika kann sein.
Kaliumspierende Urethika.
Spironolakton.
Okay.
Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Hyperkalemi?
Okay, ich muss das ...
Bei Hyperkalemi erwarte ich ...
Kamaphilimar.
Erwarte ich Kamaphilimar.
Und noch anderes ...
Nein.
Neural Influence. Okay.
Okay.
Und auch ...
Ich möchte ...
Kamaphilimar. Ja.
Okay.
Wie können Sie die Hyperkalemi behandeln?
Ich würde gerne ...
Kaliumglykonat intravenos verabreichen oder angeben.
Warum verabreichen Sie eine Kaliumglykonat?
Beim schweren Fällen würde ich ...
Ist das schweren Fällen? Ja.
Was ist Ihr Ziel?
Mein Ziel ist ...
Verbinden ...
die Hyperkalemi mit Kalium. Ja.
Was ist das?
Kaliumglykonat verabreichen wir zum Protektion des Herzens.
Okay.
Für Herzsymptome. Ja.
Und ...
durch Insulin und Glykos in die Zellen zu verschieben.
Kalium in die Zellen zu verschieben.
Oder Beta-Sympathomimatik kann man ...
kann ich ...
als Therapie ...
durchführen.
Okay. Was haben Sie noch heute?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich habe ...
Martinis Temma ...
aufgenommen.
Sie ist 60 Jahre alt.
Geboren am 23.20.65.
Sie ist 1,65 Meter und wiegt 65,2 Kilo.
Sie kam zu uns heute wegen ...
seit 3 Stunden plötzlich aufgetretenen ...
Brustschmerzen.
Die Charakteren des Schmerzens sind ...
Schmerzen sind?
Die Schmerzen sind ...
drückend und ...
dumpfartig.
Dumpf.
Die Schmerzen schüttern in den ...
Skapula.
In den Skapula.
Und ...
die Schmerzintensität ...
am Anfang ...
fünf ...
Intensität lag am Anfang ...
bei 5,10 auf einem ...
NRS.
Aber jetzt liegt bei 3,10 ...
auf dem NRS.
Diese Schmerzen ...
dauern auf der ...
und sie berichten ...
über ähnliche Beschwerden ...
vor vier Wochen.
Das war ...
ein Beispiel ...
und bei belastungabhängigen Schmerzen.
Begleitend Symptome ...
sind ...
Übelkeit.
Einmal Erbrüchen heute Morgen.
Das waren nur SNS, Kaltschweiß ...
und Müdigkeit.
Asthenie kann ich sagen vielleicht.
Sie berichtet auch ...
Schlafstörungen ...
wegen der Stress.
Sie erwähnt ...
Sie erwähnt, dass ...
sie ins Privatleben und ...
ins Arbeitsumfeld ...
schwieriges Stress ...
hat.
Haben.
Und ...
hat.
Sie ist ...
vor Erkrankungen leidet sie an ...
chronische Bronchitis.
Dagegen nimmt sie keine Medikamente.
Und auch ...
Varitzen ...
dagegen hat sie ...
einmal ...
Operation durchgeführt.
Würde bei sie ...
einmal Operation durchgeführt.
Seit fünf Jahren.
Würde bei ihr eine Operation durchgeführt.
Würde bei ihr ...
eine Operation durchgeführt.
Und sie leidet unter auch ...
Kniegelenkenarthrose.
Oder vielleicht leidet an Kniegelenkenarthrose.
Das heißt ...
Gonarthros.
Aber rechte Beine ...
rechte Beine habe ich nicht vergessen.
Als Relevanten ...
Das ist nicht wichtig.
Das ist nicht wichtig und du sagst nicht.
Nur Relevanten, ja.
Als Relevanten ...
sie ist ...
sie entspricht über ...
acht Jahren ...
acht Packages.
Oder ...
Packungjahre.
Sie raubt seit acht Jahren ...
nicht ein Package.
Sorry, ich habe falsch gerechnet.
Dort.
Ich habe gehört sie raubt seit ...
seit ...
mit ...
Sie haben recht.
Ich stand dort.
Sie ist ...
Sie raubt ...
20 Zigaretten ...
seit 44 Jahren.
Das heißt sie entspricht ...
22 Packages.
Packungjahres.
44 Packages.
Ja, ja, nicht halb.
Und trinkt Alkohol.
Ein Glas Wein am Wochenende.
Drogenkonsum würden verneint.
Sie ist Taxifahrerin.
Deswegen hat sie Stress im Leben.
Und ...
Ja.
In der Familie Anamnese ...
Sie hat ...
berichtet, dass ihr Bruder ...
bei Passoperationen ...
durchgeführt würden.
Und ihr Vater ...
Vater auch ...
Demans.
Demans oder Leidenschaft.
Ja.
Frau Stemmers ...
bei Schwerden ...
passen zu ...
Akutis coronare syndrome.
Da viel sprechen ...
sie hat Belastung ...
Passen zu akutis coronare syndrome.
Dativ.
Akutis coronare syndrome.
Das ist das.
Das macht dativ.
Akutis coronare syndrome.
Ja, richtig.
Passen zu akutis coronare syndrome.
Da spricht dafür ...
dass sie ...
seit drei Stunden ...
anfangs ...
Brustschmerzen ...
zwischen den ...
Schwerden aus.
Und ...
Stress, ...
Kaltschweißigkeit, Übelkeit, einmal Erbrechen.
Und ...
Stressbelastung in ...
ihr Leben.
Und natürlich ...
Nikotin, Konsum und auch ...
Familienbelastung.
Ich würde gerne diese Patienten ...
Differentialdiagnosen kommen.
Auch ...
Kommen auch ...
Welche Fragen haben Sie ...
während der Anamnesgesprächs ...
um ein paar ...
Differentialdiagnosen ausgesprochen?
Ja, ich habe leider ...
keine ...
nur Kopflichdenken ...
in dem Kopf denken.
Ich würde gerne ...
während der Untersuchung ...
durchgeführt ...
Warum ...
Das ist eine dringende Situation.
Deswegen habe ich nicht ...
gestellt.
Ja, aber Sie haben Recht.
Ich sollte besonders ...
... ein paar Fragen stellen.
Ja.
Okay.
Ja, an Differentialdiagnosen ...
Ja.
Ich würde gerne dieses ...
Wobei ist Differentialdiagnose?
Was würden Sie als Differentialdiagnose nennen?
Nein, das wäre ...
Refluxkrankheit.
Aber ...
Ja.
Und Lungenembolie.
Okay.
Vielleicht auch die Sektion ...
kann sein.
Ich empfehle Ihnen nur zwei Differentialdiagnosen zu nennen.
Das ist einfacher.
Ja.
Und gerne Lungenembolie sind sehr gut.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne diese Patienten ...
Intensivstationaraufnahme.
Und habe ich diese ...
Ich habe ...
Ich würde die Patienten ...
... Intensivstationaraufnahme aufnehmen.
Aufnehmen, ja.
Wenn Sie Intensivstationaraufnahme ...
... sagen, sollen Sie noch ...
... ein Werk ...
... sagen.
Ja. Ich würde gerne diese Patienten ...
Intensivstationaraufnahme aufnehmen.
Habe ich Anamnese untergebracht ...
... und einen Zugang anlegen.
Habe ich einen Zugang angelegt.
Und ...
... ein ...
... Antiemetika verabreicht.
Und ...
... Aspirin IV 300 mg ...
... verabreicht.
Und ...
Ich habe direkt ...
... kardiologisches Konzil angefordert.
Sollte ...
Ich habe Blut abgenommen.
Bei der Blut würde ich gerne ...
... Entzündungsbild ...
... Entzündungsparameter ...
... Herzmuskelentzümen ...
... und Nierenwerte ...
... bestimmen lassen.
Und ...
Natürlich habe ich ...
... EKG ...
... geschrieben.
EKG geschrieben.
Und sollte sich meine Diagnose ...
... feststellen ...
... würde ich gerne ...
Ja ...
Würde ich gerne ...
... nach der ...
... nach der Befunde ...
... nach der Befunde die Ergebnis ...
... würde ich gerne auch ...
Nein, Entschuldigung.
Nach der Befunde ...
... wäre ...
... Koronarengiografie erforderlich sein.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich empfehle Ihnen ...
... zur weiteren Abklärung ...
... werde ich die Patienten ...
... eine neue Entzündungsbefragung ...
... vornehmen.
Ich habe schon die Vitalparameter überprüft.
EKG geschrieben und etwas Blut abnehmen.
Ich habe auch ...
... eine Antiemethika ...
... Aspirin oder Schmerzmittel verabreicht.
Danach ...
... werde ich auch eine ...
... Konditorenabteilung für ...
... Kardiologie anfordern.
Das ist eine Struktur.
Körperliche Untersuchungen und ...
... was Sie gemacht haben ...
... alle haben Sie erwähnt.
Danach sollen Sie auf ...
... Kardiologie anfordern und ...
... Eko ...
... durchgeführt werden.
Danach sollten Sie ...
... Ihre Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen.
Dann sollen Sie die Patienten ...
... intensiv stationär aufnehmen.
Ja.
Dann sollten die Patienten intensiv stationär aufgenommen werden.
Ich glaube ...
... nach ...
... nachdem Sie ...
... die Ergebnisse der Patienten ...
... gesehen haben ...
... können Sie die Patienten in intensiv stationär aufnehmen.
Nicht sofort.
Und dann ...
... können Sie andere Therapieoptionen erklären.
Ja, sollte die Patienten intensiv stationär aufgenommen.
Vielleicht können Sie sagen ...
... die Sauerstoffgabe ...
... und Heparin ...
... nach ...
... den Ergebnissen ...
... eine coronarengeografische Erfordernis sein.
Ja.
Sie haben alles gesagt.
Aber brauchen Sie ...
... die letzten zwei Teilen ...
... zur weiteren Abklärung ...
... weitere Prozesse und Therapie ...
... brauchen Sie ein bisschen Struktur.
Ja.
Normalerweise haben Sie alles gesagt.
Aber wenn Sie in einer Struktur erwähnt ...
Das ist wichtig.
... kann der Prüfer oder die Prüfer besser verstehen.
Natürlich.
Ja.
Ich habe ein paar Anfällen.
Danke.
Ich möchte Ihnen sagen, dass Sie es toll gemacht haben.
Ich bin sehr glücklich.
Sie haben sich sehr gut entwickelt.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Ich versuche es für Ihre Zufriedenheit.
Nein, nein, das ist nicht zufrieden.
Sie sind sehr ruhig.
Sie sind sehr gut.
Sie haben die Sicherheit der Menschen.
Ich freue mich sehr.
Sie haben sich sehr gut gefühlt.
Sie hören die Patienten sehr gut.
Sie verstehen sie sehr gut.
Sie können sich mit ihnen kommunizieren.
Ich möchte Ihnen ein paar Anfälle nennen.
In der Grammatik ...
Du hast gesagt, was bedeutet sie.
Was bedeutet sie?
Ich kann es nicht erinnern.
Du hast gesagt, was bedeutet sie?
Kann man das als was meinen sie nennen?
Du hast gesagt, was bedeutet sie.
Wir nennen sie was meinen sie.
Aber mit das Wort zum Wort aus der Grammatik ist nicht genannt.
Ich mache dasladen.
Du hast gesagt, was bedeutet sie.
Du hast gesagt, ...
Aber es ist ein Risikofaktor, oder?
Es ist ein Problem mit dem Alter. Ich finde es nicht so logisch, ein Jahr zuerst, ein Jahr später.
Es ist kein großer Fehler, wenn du es nennst, dann erklärst du es.
Oh Gott, ist das gut. Okay.
Was habe ich noch gesagt?
Du hast es gesagt, wenn du aus Auslösen fragst, dass es nicht gut ist.
Auslösen müssen sich für die Krankheit befassen.
Hier kannst du direkt das beantworten, und du wirst auch den Pneumatomatsch ausfüllen.
Ja.
Du wirst den Pneumatomatsch ausfüllen, wenn du das fragst.
Aber wenn du das nicht gut findest, ist es nicht gut.
Du kannst es fragen, ob es mit Lumbargie oder Heiswirbel, Zolle und Schmersen geht.
Aber das ist nicht gut.
Du hast es gesagt, dass es nicht gut ist.
Aber in der Beziehung ist es nicht gut.
Du musstest nur das, was du vorher hast, benutzen.
Und dann ...
Du hast ein Problem mit dem Schlaf. Du hast dich damit interessiert.
Du hast ein paar Fragen gestellt.
Du hast die Zeit gebraucht.
Ich habe 21 Minuten gebraucht, aber du hast es schon fertig gemacht.
Ich habe es etwas zu spät gemacht.
Ich habe 22 Minuten gebraucht.
Aber es war gut.
Ich hoffe, dass wir es auf die Zeit verarbeiten.
Ob wir es auf die Zeit verarbeiten, oder nicht.
Du hast etwas über den Schlaf zu tun.
Du hast ein Problem mit dem Interessiertem.
Aber es kann ein Problem sein, um die Zeit zu verbrauchen.
Nur, dass du es verstehst.
Das ist nicht voll.
Das ist eine Stresswürde.
Das reicht.
Du hast es über den Schlaf zu tun, als du den Schlaf zu fragen hast.
Ich habe mich gespannt, was du fragen wirst.
Vielleicht kannst du es kurz fragen.
Du kannst es so als octaves sagen.
Du kannst es nicht so sagen, dass du eine Intensivstation für ein Kind hast.
Es gibt keine Resonanz.
Vielleicht kannst du es nicht sagen.
Du kannst es schon sagen.
Warum hast du es so richtig für den Kind?
Sadece was du tun kannst, sag es dir.
Für die weitere ganzen Informationen, die du für dich machen kannst,
für alles, was dich für dich verbreitet,
ist es wichtig, dass du dir etwas sagen kannst,
wie du dir eine Information geben willst.
Das ist auch so in der normalen Leben.
Wenn wir, wenn wir viele Dinge erwarten,
sehr viel über uns denken,
wenn wir mit dem Ergebnis arbeiten,
müssen wir es nicht direkt den Patienten sagen.
Man muss die Patienten ein bisschen anwenden.
Man muss sie in 10 Minuten anwenden.
Wir können es nicht direkt anwenden.
Wir sagen es erst so, 10 Minuten später,
und dann sagen wir, dass wir das Ergebnis bekommen haben.
Einige Krankheiten sind in 2 Stunden.
Aber um nicht zu schockieren,
ist es so.
Deswegen ist es nicht intensiv stationär.
Ich werde es nicht so sagen.
Ich habe schon diese Dinge gemacht.
Ich werde dich auch als Kardiolog sehen.
Ich werde dich auch als Eko-Kardiografie machen.
Ich werde dann mit dir reden,
wenn du die Ergebnisse hast.
Ich werde mit dir darüber reden.
Das würde mir besser aus dem Patienten-Ausgabe kommen.
Das habe ich mir gedacht.
So habe ich das vergessen.
Es gibt nichts.
Danke.
Und auch,
der Vater ist tot.
Der Vater ist tot?
Ja, der Vater ist tot.
Du kannst dort die Reaktion normalerweise zeigen.
Aber wenn du es nicht da siehst,
kannst du sagen, dass es nicht gut ist.
Ja.
Es ist nicht Zeit.
Der Vater ist tot.
Der Rest ist uns.
Ja.
Schönen Abend.
Ich habe es wirklich so gesagt.
Es war sehr schön.
Ich wollte heute Ketin-Höckels verkaufen.
Nein, ich konnte es nicht verkaufen.
Es war gut.
Wir haben die Kugeln kaputt.
Es ist wirklich schwierig.
Du hast es sehr gut gemacht.
Du hast mich nicht so müde gemacht.
Danke.
Es war das erste Mal,
dass wir das Kugeln kaputt haben.
Ich weiß nicht, das war das erste Mal.
Wir haben es mit Ibrahim gearbeitet.
So?
Mit Ibrahim, der in den Test kam.
Ja, es gibt andere Bedeutungen.
Es gibt nicht nur die Bedeutungen,
die man in der Sache hat.
Es gibt auch eine Art,
wie man es in der Sache macht.
Ich habe Ketin-Ausgabe
von ihm von derutenant.
Durch Blutungsstörung
das Herzes-
Das Herzes,
das hat er gesagt,
das ist aber als Herz
durch Blutungsstörung.
Du kannst es als Herz-Gefäßes
das Herz-Gefäßes
das Herzes-Gefäßes
Herz-Gefäßes
Okay.
Eigentlich heißt es Herz-Kurs-Gefäßes.
Ja, Hetzkuss auf.